mais que se passe-t-il avec kilian m
bape et le jeune prodige serait-il
devenu incontrôlable c'est la question
que se posent de nombreux supporters
après sa sortie très remarquée ce week
end si lors du match qui opposait le psg
et montpellier tout semblait se passer
pour le mieux sur le terrain un incident
est survenu à la 69e minute du jeu et a
fait basculer cette joie collective en
tensions internes dans le club parisien
malgré un très bon match au cours duquel
le numéro 7 a même marqué un but le
trancher
thomas ce tour l entraîneur de paris a
pris la décision de remplacer mbp au
cours du match
un choix stratégique qui n'a visiblement
pas du tout plu aux jeunes prodiges
un échange musclé avec son coach mais ce
n'est pas tout alors qu'il quittait la
pelouse qu'il y a même tapé à rejeter
d'un signe du bras la doudoune tendu par
un intendant du psg une attitude
agressive que de nombreux supporters ont
condamné tourelles lui même en
conférence de presse a souligné qu'il
n'avait pas beaucoup aimé l'attitude
désinvolte du joueur chez suis pas en
colère pour moi je suis triste
visiblement qui viennent m a fait n'est
toujours pas calmé après le match de
nombreux internautes ont remarqué le
petit jeu du joueur parisien qui se
seraient amusés à licques et de
nombreuses photos des joueurs du real de
madrid
une ultime provocation alors une
question se pose maintenant au psg
autant du côté des supporters que du
club quillanais mbappé aurait-il pris la
grosse tête
je connais c'est un amour de mec
et voilà et il n'a pas du tout pris la
grosse tête mais c'est quand vous êtes
dans un match plein
quand on vous fait sortir battait set ça
t'énerve aussi oui mais le pêcheur
charmante votre avis et je connais et
killian franchement un super mec moi
j'aime beaucoup
il manifeste son amour du maillot son
amour de la compétition il a envie de
jouer et marquer plus de buts mais ce
que je trouve que son entraîneur et pas
très cool de le choper à la sortie alors
un public me connaît je connais aussi
très bientôt ma collègue qui est un
amour de mecs aussi d'entrée l'audimat
mois voilà le truc qui me dérange et je
vous lis on a une super star mondiale
ah oui le mec qui fait rêver le monde
entier et on les en train dont la montée
pendant des semaines et des semaines et
des semaines et là les mecs cherche tout
le temps la petite bête sûr qu'il ya
même pas pu écrire un truc ils essaient
de brûler leurs idoles comme à chaque
fois à l'effet que je suis intéressé un
support parce qu'elle que charrier
laissez le jouer un mouvement d'humeur
c'est pas mais oui grands attaquants
sont égoïstes mais qu'il y en ait maps
et il doit comprendre qu'à d'autres
échéances de paris saint germain
mais qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit si dix
minutes plus tard il s'était blessé 5 0
on sort qu'il y en ait mme baclet c'est
normal mais où une ville du championnat
son entraîneur mais juste tous les mecs
qui lui tombe dessus à cause de ça parce
qu'ils essaient de trouver un truc soit
simple accessible août à une analyse là
dessus quoi qu'est ce t'en penses toi
oui moi je les aime bien de même après
le fait qu'il ait les joueurs du real
madrid c'est un peu genre un pionnier du
genre à la mer sont un peu je peux
partir la barre avec qui a jamais eu des
sautes d'humeur envers sa chaîne où on
verse alors arrêtez moi regarder mon
tweet devant
redis j'ai défoncé le groupe est bon on
n'était pas à 100 foot on est comme ça
on dit ce qu'il a à dire waouh il fasse
encore des tas la grosse tête avait une
famille voilà je vous le dis oui il est
encore le vieux con de service mais je
trouve qu'ils grondent dirai comment ça
une faute personnelle il se grandirait à
la fois être un génie du foot et
respecter son entraîneur espère alors ça
se terminerait pas sortir du bus a
pendant la coupe du monde c'est un peu
une manière de dire pense aux autres
aussi qui sont sur le banc et qui part
aussi joué un moment coin et moi je
pense qu'à 20 ans d'un droit d'avoir des
petits coups de sang et c'est ce qui
importe quel nom mais c'est plus
excusable devient une crécelle après
trop vieux france alors la semaine
passée téléspectateurs mais je trouve
qu'il a abusé mois
[Rires]
rousseau qui a 70 ans je suis vraiment
quoi c'est bon ça va quoi moi aussi j'ai
mis trois buts je n'ai pas toutes ces
histoires
non mais on le connaît un peu ça c'est
un super mec et thomas stocker l'eau si
c'est un amour d'entraîneur dommage
lembras on est rarement j'ai un trou
dans l'ensemble